welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and one division is one of the
biggest mysteries in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe both it's bonkers
reality swapping concept east and early
promo footage and now that our world is
plagued by production delays and unknown
release date on Disney Plus which isn't
just a problem because we're all thirsty
for our Marvel stories one division
unlike other MCU titles like black widow
or the Falcon the Winter Soldier looks
like it could have some of the broadest
implications on the MCU at large this
apparent mental breakdown by the Scarlet
Witch looks to many of us comic fans
like a possible adaptation of the
crucial House of M event which could
introduce mutants to the Marvel films
this is why hungry hungry psychos have
been chomping at Elizabeth Olsen's
recent Instagram posts the Wanda vision
star has been deliberately baiting
Avengers fans with clues that look a lot
more like innocent progress reports on
her home garden I wish I could stop
there I really do because Olsen is
clearly just a goofy garden troll but
this madman has also mind through toys
shirts Pat's cakes license plates hair
clocks CGI upper lips you name it
looking for clues and if I could turn
two seconds of Loki into nine minutes of
insane crack patent I can definitely
spare some dignity by giving Elizabeth
Olsen's horticultural hobby and each
weekday okay let's review the timeline
in early April Olsen began posting
Instagram stories about her home garden
and activity that many of those
sheltering in place have found to be
productive and healthy though those
suckers haven't tried a tweet down then
Olsen posted this and for all the
Avengers fans out there
the shelling peas strawberry chard kale
baby broccolis father's and the garlic
they were planted in late February and
their tomatoes were a plan to the first
week of March oh do not at the avengers
tribe we have nothing to do and we will
tear apart your crops faster than Peter
can rabbit one of those brave souls was
mr. Greg Dane universe at geek feed who
ran an article about Olsen's post and
offered an airtight color-coded theory
interpreting Olsen's crops as clues for
the production dates for one division
the red anime
and looky the green veggies as they
often say in the comments on this
channel maybe he's onto something or
maybe he's reaching Olson herself got a
kick out of that interpretation because
shortly after it went up she posted a
few screen caps of the geek feed article
underlining the color coded theory with
corresponding colors and including the
caption can you read between the lines
at this point any sane mind won't not us
but you know the same ones assumed Olson
was joking all caps on the you ellipses
question mark could this be any more the
chandler of sarcastic punctuation but
then on April 10th Olson posted an
Instagram story that I think deserves
closer inspection I have another Secret
Avengers thing for you meathook holy so
I should clarify that this is probably
just a board movie star flexing about
her homegrown fruits and veggies but is
it possible that there's a clue here
that Olson herself might not be fully
aware of notice the faux dramatic pearls
clutching pose at Olsen's strikes in the
way she repeats Oh strawberries so crew
hidden in the sing-songy Mary Poppins
way with the video cutting off at the
third one we know from the Wanda bitchin
promo footage that the show will
introduce Wanda's children who in the
House of M event and later comics are
the mutants Wiccan and speed Wiccan is a
member of the Young Avengers Billy
Kaplan and the bee art on the fridge
looks like a nod knew him in house of M
Wanda materializes kids says her chaotic
mind resets reality and various
hypotheticals it ends with her chanting
no more mutants and her kids vanish and
later we find out that Wiccan and speed
are those kids reincarnated it's
confusing Wiccan like Scarlet Witch uses
sorcery and repeated incantations to
evoke that magic so just go with me on
this could Olsen's performative pose and
repeated musical chants be the mind of
an actress subconsciously tapping back
into her most recent emotionally
demanding role that involves a maternal
invocation of genetic offspring a scene
that might require this actress to
portray a grieving mother freaking out
that her babies won't
into something more but then chanting as
if willing into existence a new life a
new life a new life and then BOOM
mutants an MCU book folks I get what's
going on in the minds of our Avengers as
they lose it while in isolation because
I too am in isolation I am exactly the
same as Scarlet Witch in every way but
because I don't have a backyard garden I
stayed nourished with bang energy and
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right there's no blimpy 12
ounce cans here it contains 300
milligrams of caffeine it is sugar-free
and it has zero calories yet it tastes
great
there are over 20 different flavors to
choose from one of those great flavors
is Purple Haze it's delicious it tastes
like purple and it puts you in a good
kind of haze not the crazy kind restart
to speed things between the lines of
Instagram stories check out bang on
Instagram you can get 25% off your order
at bank - energy calm when you use the
code new rockstars 25 there you can buy
cans of bang energy including their
sweet tea keto coffee flavors Purple
Haze a flavor that tastes like a Prince
concert you can also get clothing
fitness supplements and all kinds of
stuff to be your best bang self thanks
again a bang energy for sponsoring this
video get 25% off at bang - energy calm
using the code new rockstars 25 and
follow the inventor of bang on instagram
at bang energy at CEO
look yes I am reading into Olsen's post
probably a bit too much and you're gonna
say I'm exactly the Avengers nerd
reading between the lines if she's
trolling like I'd get the joke but also
in another life I was once a performer
who had been in the midst of long
commitments to stage shows - musicals
web series psychologically demanding
roles that start to feel like my own
identity and then seep into my regular
day-to-day life rules like sassy vlogger
that would have been recurring if the
producer has made a second season
instead of switching their majors actors
are weird you will find them slipping
into their character voices humming
their solos re-enacting emotional beats
in their everyday lives this is how we
get Ren fairs delightful Graham Norton
interviews every time I see how she said
you've not been doing me again
why Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
during their Oscars duet looked like
they were actually about to do it on
that piano Elizabeth Olsen wouldn't even
be the first MCU actor to fall into this
Tom Holland hands over the secrets of
MCU future its carelessly as Peter
Parker hands over Tony Stark's
sunglasses to Mysterio Mark Ruffalo
leaked spoilers with a soft-spoken
innocence that Bruce Banner has when
he's trying to stay calm and not offend
anyone one division more than any other
MCU title before it is going to be truly
dependent on the actors performance the
nuances of Olsen's voice her expressions
or physicality all of those are crucial
to the toggling sitcom realities of the
show before clue hunters had to pay
close attention to the nuances of VFX
mocap unitards or evidence of
post-production trickery in trailers but
now when Elizabeth Olsen does an
impression of Lucille Ball or Roseanne
or Marcia Brady that could actually tell
us a lot about the plot of one of these
episodes so win Olsen clutches her
jacket and slips into this vulnerable
frantic state when she gleefully nurses
her dumb strawberries to life by singing
to them like she's Mary Poppins
repeating it three times the brain of a
light like there be loose it wouldn't
surprise me if these are the same
gestures voices and mannerisms the
character Wanda Maximoff makes it she
frantically conceives the future
Avengers and uses sorcery to chant
babies in and out of existence look did
Elizabeth Olsen intend for us to read
her insta stories this way Anna no
probably not but did Tommy and Zack
during a recent improv comedy show
intend to slip and do impressions of
whole Kokan and Macho Man Randy Savage
unprovoked because they've done these
voices dozens of times and it's their
comfort zones and performers are by
nature constantly maddeningly on so yeah
take it from this failed actor Lizzy
Olson is growing mutant babies in her
garden and she will be selling the cast
of Avengers 5 at the Studio City Farmers
Market comment down below with your
wanna bitchin theories join our
recurring MCU watch alongs on discord
right becoming a patreon at patreon.com
slash new rockstars and while you're on
instagram obsessing over elizabeth olsen
stories follow me an da boss follow new
rockstars it subscribe here on YouTube
for future tweet downs of Taika Waititi
sports
[Music]